[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Conan O'Brien here welcome to my video
blog here's what's going going on in the
world last last week I went to Jamba
Juice and I got I got a smoothie with
all 22 boosts added to it I haven't
slept in three days and earlier today I
peed laser beams all right it's time for
my new segment of the video blog it's
called precious moments with Tommy Lee
Jones Precious Moments little Tommy Lee
Jones this is where I show pictures of
Tommy Lee Jones reacting to very
emotional moments in his life here he is
watching his grandson take his first
steps here he is on his birthday walking
into a surprise party here he is after a
long relaxing massage here he is
watching the YouTube video of a baby
panda with hiccups that was fun this
next segment is dedicated to our troops
it's called Dustin Diamond Phillips
those new Diamond Phillips this is where
I take photos of the TV show Saved by
the Bell and replace screeches face with
Lou Diamond Phillips
here he is hanging with his buds Zack
and Slater
here he is lacing up his rollerskates
for the big contest here even asking
that lady from showgirls to the prom and
then oh this one's a mistake
this photo is from another segment
called Lou Diamond Wilson Phillips
Neil Diamond Wilson Phillips all right
there's a lot of stuff going on in the
world that needs to be commented on so
this last segment is called animals with
emotions animals with emotions there's a
lizard that just found out McDonald's
brought back the McRib
[Laughter]
there's a baboon they just overheard
what happened with Al Roker here's a
bear that just sexually harassed a
penguin
pretty cocky about it this is the
penguin that just said oh no you did
and this is a sheep it's getting turned
on by all this sexual harassment oh and
finally this is Tommy Lee Jones watching
this bit
[Applause]